well andy i mentioned this earlier this
week but uh let's face it you and i are
pretty big trivia buffs yeah we we
played a trivia game earlier this week
it was fun
we sure did now the first time we played
your questions were a little intense i
just want to make sure this time you
understand
it's just a friendly simple trivia
competition okay
conan i already told you there is
nothing friendly about trivia
whatever let's go richter all right
let's do it
all right here goes who had the starring
role in the 2014 sci-fi
adventure movie interstellar matthew
mcconaughey
correct all right all right all right
thank you and your
spot-on impressions thank you thank you
classic all right my turn
you ready yep the rms
lusitania was a british ocean liner
launched in 1906
that made many transatlantic crossings
before it was torpedoed
and sunk by a german u-boat during world
war one
okay actually i know quite a bit about
world war one i'm a history
fan so what are the current longitude
and latitude coordinates of the rms
lusitania shipwreck
andy that that's like just like last
time that that
no one knows the answer to that question
it's way too complicated
they're just coordinates colin i mean
don't you know how the ocean works
i know how the ocean works just give me
a simple question
all right here you go easy peasy
what color ah so far so good
was the building that served new
zealand's first cable tramway line that
opened in 1881.
oh andy come on it's called trivia
because the questions are supposed to be
trivial simple fun oh my god okay
i'll give you a real simple one
which 5g carrier is fast reliable and
secure
why that's att 5g
that's right conan it's not complicated
indeed
18t 5g is a no-brainer it's not
complicated it's a no-brainer it's not
complicated
it's a no-brainer